[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg
schön dass Sie dabei sind wie auch
Norbert Lehmann für den Sport von mir
großer Tag für alle Fußballfreunde und
Freundinnen
Auftakt in Downunder Neuseeland und
Australien begrüßen 32 Teams zur größten
Frauenfußball-WM aller Zeiten
Wut auf Schweden in Bagdad stürmen
Muslime die schwedische Botschaft
auslöser sind Koranverbrennungen in
Stockholm
und Löwenjagd in Brandenburg südlich von
Berlin wird das Raubtier gesichtet die
Polizei startet eine aufwendige
Suchaktion
[Musik]
es ist soweit die Frauenfußball-WM ist
eröffnet so groß wie noch nie erstmals
in zwei Ländern und erstmals bekommen
die Spielerinnen direkt Prämien von der
FIFA die liegen allerdings immer noch
deutlich unter denen der Männer Volker
über den Start der WM die nach
fifa-event aller Zeiten werden könnte
Neuseeland ist ein kleines Fußballland
aber feiern können die Neuseeländer wie
eine große Fußballnation Feuer von denen
und eine spektakuläre Lichtshow
die Geschichte der indigenen Völker der
Gastgeberländer stehen bei der
auftaktfeier in Auckland im Mittelpunkt
32 Teams sind bei der WM dabei so viele
wie noch nie 64 Spiele in vier Wochen zu
groß das ganze meinen die ein andere
Sehnen gerade darin eine Chance für die
kleineren Nationen
und dieses Geld kann man wieder in die
Entwicklung des Produktes Frauenfußball
stecken und deswegen ist das wirklich
eine große Plattform fast ein kleines
Trampolin für ganz viele Nationen der
erste WM-Tag begann allerdings mit einer
Schreckensnachricht ein 24-jähriger
erschießt zwei Menschen nicht weit
entfernt von der Fanmeile mindestens
sechs Menschen sind verletzt beschütze
ist tot offenbar ein Einzeltäter ein
Schock auch für die deutschen
Nationalspielerin
wir fühlen uns auf jeden Fall sicher mit
unseren Sicherheitsbeauftragten und ja
werden das glaube ich jetzt auch nicht
weiter dann thematisieren
die Veranstalter entscheiden dann doch
dass Eröffnung Spiel anzufeifen
und da schlägt der Gastgeber Neuseeland
den Favoriten aus Norwegen Neuseeland
feiert den gelungenen Start in die
Weltmeisterschaft euphorisch
mehr zu den Spielen von heute hat in ein
paar Minuten Norbert Lehmann und alles
was sie sonst über die Frauen WM wissen
müssen gibt es in der ZDF heute App zum
Beispiel auf wen trifft das deutsche
Team wer spielt überhaupt alles mit und
wann laufen die Spieler eigentlich
Stichwort Zeitverschiebung
jetzt zum Krieg in der Ukraine die
massiven russischen Angriffe auf
ukrainische Hafenstädte erfordern eine
Antwort der Europäischen Union das sagt
der Außenbeauftragte der EU Josef Borell
rief heute die Mitgliedsländer auf ihre
milliardenschweren Militärhilfen
deutlich aufzustocken und weitere Luft
Verteidigungssysteme zu liefern Isabel
Schäfers berichtet
die Schäden in Odessa heute morgen sind
massiv nach drei Nächten verheerender
Luftangriffe auf die Ukraine auch der
Hafen wurde bombardiert Getreidelager in
Brand gesetzt laut Kiew rund 60.000
Tonnen Getreide zerstört diese Bilder
der vergangenen Tage bestimmten auch das
Treffen der EU-Außenminister in Brüssel
dass der russische Präsident das
getreideabkommen aufgekündigt hat und
nun auch noch den Hafen von Odessa
umbardiert ist nicht nur eine erneuter
Angriff auf die Ukraine sondern es ist
ein Angriff auf die Menschen auf die
ärmsten Menschen auf dieser Welt diese
letzten drei Nächte erfordern von uns
eine Antwort und diese Antwort kann
abgesehen von der Rhetorik nur eine sein
die Bereitstellung von mehr
militärischen Mitteln
der Vorschlag zusätzliche 20 Milliarden
Euro Militärhilfe in den nächsten vier
Jahren doch bisher ist nicht klar ob
alle EU-Mitgliedstaaten das mittragen
und wie genau das finanziert werden soll
neben der konkreten Unterstützung für
die Ukraine berrieten die Außenminister
auch über eine mögliche Annäherung
zwischen der EU und der Türkei der Tenor
ein EU-Beitritt der Türkei sei derzeit
nicht denkbar das Land aber als
strategischer Partner wichtig ich will
nur sagen dass die Türkei sich ja Mühe
gegeben hat und geholfen hat dieses
getreideabkommen hinzukriegen die Türkei
ich glaube ich das einzige Land hier was
ich sehe was einen Anschluss auf Putin
hat um dieses getreideabkommen was ja
die ganze Welt betrifft wieder zustande
zu bringen die EU sucht weiter nach
Möglichkeiten die Ukraine zu
unterstützen und dabei wissen alle ohne
Partner ist der Handlungsspielraum in
Brüssel begrenzt
nach Deutschland die werbeauftragte des
Bundestags Eva Högl fordert mehr
Anstrengungen um Nachwuchs zu gewinnen
sonst sei das Ziel die Truppe bis 2031
auf 203.000 Soldatinnen und Soldaten zu
vergrößern nicht zu erreichen die
Bundeswehr müsse für junge Leute
attraktiver gemacht werden sagte Hügel
dem redaktionsnetzwerk Deutschland
Nachwuchs verzweifelt gesucht wird auch
im Handwerk dort gibt es reichlich zu
tun aber die Fachkräfte fehlen zwar sind
bis Ende Juni rund 64.000
Ausbildungsverträge geschlossen worden
das sind fast vier Prozent mehr als im
Vorjahr aber es gibt noch ca 36.000
offene Plätze ein Plus von knapp sieben
Prozent für die Handwerksbetriebe die
noch suchen heißt das jetzt entsperrt
Anja Chalet
die Auftragsbücher der Firma wärmetec in
Coswig bei Dresden sind übervoll die
Fachleute für Heizungs- und Kältetechnik
haben sich vor allem auf den Einbau von
Wärmepumpen spezialisiert sie kommen mit
der Arbeit gar nicht hinterher bereits
seit drei vier Jahren gibt es Probleme
Nachwuchs zu finden aktuell sind drei
Ausbildungsplätze nicht besetzt wir
können teilweise nicht alle Kunden
befriedigen zufriedenstellen und müssen
teilweise sagen ja entweder ihr wartet
bis 2025 wo viele sagen oh ist sonst
nichts ne wir schieben einfach das was
wir machen sollen Energiewende schieben
mir vor uns ja weil wir das nicht machen
können weil wir keine Leute haben
insgesamt sind in Sachsen vor Beginn des
neuen Ausbildungsjahres noch rund 1.300
Lehrstellen im Handwerk nicht besetzt
die Handwerkskammer Dresden hat eine
Lehrstellenbörse eingerichtet um
Nachwuchs zu gewinnen müsse es generell
ein Umdenken in der Gesellschaft geben
es ist ja erstaunlicherweise so dass das
viele Menschen sagen ja das Handwerk ist
wichtig wenn es aber dann darum geht was
sollen die eigenen Kinder von der
Ausbildungsweg beschreiten dann wird
dann doch eher abgeraten und viele
Eltern neigen immer noch dazu ihren
Kindern eben ein Studium zu empfehlen
Nico Ulrich hat sich bewusst für einen
Handwerksberuf entschieden seine
Ausbildung bei wärmetet bereits vor
einiger Zeit abgeschlossen positiv an
seinem Job sieht er vor allem die
Vielseitigkeit in dem Beruf man fährt
von Haus zu Haus baut neue Werbung ein
und das macht einfach glücklich die
Leute glücklich zu sehen
und man könne auch ganz gut davon leben
sagt der 20-Jährige eine eigene Wohnung
habe er bereits
um die freien Stellen zu füllen braucht
Deutschland Zuwanderung braucht Menschen
aus dem Ausland die gewillt sind hier zu
leben und zu arbeiten doch gut
ausgebildete Fachkräfte sind
international heiß begehrt und
Deutschland hat nicht die allerbesten
Karten deswegen ist Arbeitsminister Heil
gerade auf Werbetour in Indien Larsson
es könnte eine Win-Win-Situation werden
in Deutschland fehlen Fachkräfte in
Indien vielen Jobs für die junge
Bevölkerung der Arbeitsminister reißt
durch den Subkontinent und trifft auf
hochmotivierte Computerfachleute und
Ingenieurinnen die bald schon ihr
berufliches Glück in Deutschland finden
wollen
meine erste Priorität war ein Land zu
finden wo ich und meine Familie
anerkannt werden und nicht
ausgeschlossen
die language ist ein bisschen schwierig
aber ich kenne ist das aber man kann die
Sprache ja lernen
in Deutschland steht in direkter
Konkurrenz zu klassischen
Einwanderungsländern wie Kanada oder den
USA dennoch hofft Hubertus Heil auf
viele Fachkräfte aus Indien wir haben
modernes Einwanderungsrecht jetzt
geschaffen Deutschland hat einen guten
Ruf Indien es gibt viele junge Menschen
die sich aufmachen Deutsch zu lernen wir
sind eine sichere Gesellschaft eine
starke Wirtschaften politische System
Deutschland ist ökonomisch auf starke
Zuwanderung angewiesen eine mangelnde
Willkommenskultur oder gar
Ausländerfeindlichkeit während der
kontraproduktiv in den Community ist
auch der indischen Fachkräfte spricht
sich schnell herum wo sehr wünscht sind
und wo nicht tatsächlich gibt es bei
vielen hier die Befürchtungen in
Deutschland mit Rassismus konfrontiert
zu werden abhalten lassen wollen sie
sich davon aber nicht
sicher gibt es Leute die uns nicht haben
wollen aber das ist ja nicht nur in
Deutschland so wir wissen dass uns
stellen uns darauf ein am Ende glaube
ich dass wir bei den meisten willkommen
sind musste schon jetzt ist Indien das
Land aus dem außerhalb Europas die
meisten Arbeitsmigranten nach
Deutschland kommen das will die
Bundesregierung noch ausbauen
die Spannungen zwischen Schweden und dem
Irak kochen hoch in Stockholm sollte
heute wieder ein Koran verbrannt werden
die Ankündigung löste im Irak Wut und
Empörung aus hunderte stürmten die
schwedische Botschaft in Bagdad die
Botschafterin wurde ausgewiesen Kritik
an Religionen ist in Schweden von der
Meinungsfreiheit gedeckt was erlaubt sei
betont die Regierung sei aber nicht
immer angemessen muss
einmal hatte es schon getan salvan
Monika selbst ernannte Islamkritiker und
Koran Verbrenner heute vor der
irakischen Botschaft im Stockholm
verzichtete darauf dass heilige Buch der
Muslime ein weiteres Mal anzuzünden
stattdessen tritt der exileraka ist mit
Füßen seine Aktion stößt auf viel Kritik
aufhören den Koran zu verbrennen muss
ihm sagen respektiere den Koran und alle
Menschen
ich finde es gut dass er den Koran nicht
verbrannt hat denn was in der
schwedischen Botschaft im Iran passiert
ist hätte in anderen muslimischen
Ländern leicht eskalieren können
schon die bloße Ankündigungen einer
Koranverbrennung führte letzte Nacht den
Bagdad zum Sturm auf die schwedische
Botschaft hunderte aufgebrachter Muslime
setzten Teile des Gebäudes in Brand das
Botschaftspersonal konnte sich in
Sicherheit bringen die irakische
Regierung hat inzwischen die schwedische
Botschafterin des Landes verwiesen
die koranaktion in Stockholm war im
Vorfeld von der Polizei genehmigt worden
Kritik an Religionen ist in Schweden
durch die Meinungsfreiheit gedeckt
darüber ist eine Diskussion entbrannt
die Regierung hat wiederholt betont
nicht alles was erlaubt sei sei auch
angemessen
heute am 20 Juli wurde in Berlin anders
gescheiterte Attentat auf Adolf Hitler
erinnert Offiziere um Klaus Schenk Graf
von Stauffenberg hatten 1944 versucht
mit einem Sprengstoffanschlag auf Hitler
dem Nazi-Regime ein Ende zu setzen im
pendlerblock wo Staufenberg und drei
weitere Männer nach der Tat erschossen
würden mahnte Verteidigungsminister
Pistorius wachsam zu sein gegen die
heutigen Gefahren für die Demokratie
gefährdende Ausmaße an überall zum
Beispiel dort wo Menschen sich deshalb
nicht mehr trauen ein Mandat oder ein
Ehrenamt anzunehmen
das sind nicht nur Warnzeichen meine
Damen und Herren es sind laute deutliche
Weckrufe Alarmsignale
so sah mal aus der Goldschatz der Kelten
aus dem Museum Manching nach
Expertenmeinung mehrere Millionen Euro
wert leider haben die Diebe die ihn im
November stahlen zumindest ein Teil der
Münzen eingeschmolzen vier Männer wurden
festgenommen mutmaßliche Serientäter
Julian Schmidt hat Details
Schatzsucher nach dem größten keltischen
Goldfund des 20 Jahrhunderts auf dem
Grundstück eines verdächtigenden plate
in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern Graben die
Ermittler in den nach den Münzen aus dem
Museum in bayerischen Manching vier
Männer hat das bayerische LKA in
Norddeutschland und NRW festgenommen
nach einer Übergabe von Goldklumpen der
Verdacht eine Handvoll Münzen wurde für
jeden Klumpen eingeschmolzen diese
weisen nach ersten Analysen in der Stoff
Zusammensetzung weitreichende
Übereinstimmungen mit dem in Manching in
wendeten Kelten Schatz auf wir haben es
hier offensichtlich mit
berufseinbrechern zu tun insgesamt geht
es um eine vierte Millionen Euro
Materialwert die Spurensuche begann kurz
nach der Tat im November DNA an
Gegenständen die in der Nähe des
einbruchsorts gefunden wurden die vier
deutschen zwischen 42 und 50 Jahren
sollen vor dem Einbruch die
Glasfaserleitungen im Ort durchtrennt
haben keinerle möglich die Bande könnte
für mindestens acht weitere Fälle
verantwortlich sein ein verräterisches
mindestens zwei Personen ganz auffällig
oft im einen Fall mehrere dutzend mal
solche Overalls bestellt hat und auch
ganz auffällig oft einen Rucksack diesen
Tipps bestellt hatte dann hatten wir
also wirklich jetzt konkreten
Tatverdacht die Beschuldigten sollen
bereits weitere Museen ausgespäht haben
in Manching hatten sie bis zuletzt auf
einen Deal gehofft Geld gegen Gold damit
der keltenschatz nicht eingeschmolzen
wird die Suche sie ist für heute beendet
bis auf ein paar Goldklumpen bleibt der
Rest der rund 500 Münzen verschollen
er ist große Hitze dann stark Regen und
Sturmböen Norditalien und der Balkan
sind von verheerenden Unwettern
getroffen worden mindestens sechs
Menschen starben mehr als 200 wurden
verletzt im kroatischen Zagreb fickten
gestern orkanartige Böden durch die
Stadt am Tag danach
Aufräumarbeiten so ein Unwetter hätten
sie noch nicht erlebt sagen die Menschen
in der Stadt
auch was ziemlich neues erleben die
Menschen gerade im Süden Berlins passen
Sie auf wenn sie spazieren gehen und
lassen Sie Ihre Haustiere nicht raus so
warnt die Polizei mit Apps und
Lautsprechern offenbar läuft da ein
großes Raubtier frei herum
möglicherweise eine Löwin und das obwohl
kein Zoo oder Zirkus eine vermisst das
Tier muss wohl aus einem Privathaushalt
stammen Antje Klingbeil hat Details
Aufregung seit heute nach der rundum
Kleinmachnow die Polizei ist mit
Hubschraubern und Einsatzwagen vor Ort
ebenso bewaffnete Jäger in den sozialen
Medien war dieses Video eines Raubtiers
aufgetaucht in der Nacht vom Auto aus
aufgenommen vermutlich eine Löwen so die
Polizei
nach erster Sichtung sind wir von einer
Ernsthaftigkeit ausgegangen also dass es
sich tatsächlich um ein Wildtier handelt
und entsprechend haben wir sofortige
Suchmaßnahmen und Maßnahmen zum Schutz
der Bevölkerung
eingeleitet Anwohner sollen derzeit den
Wald meiden mit dem Fahrrad auf dem Weg
zur Arbeit und soll jetzt hier an der
Stelle nicht mehr weiterfahren weil sie
eine freiläufende freilaufende Löwin in
den Bereich geben sollen so ein bisschen
unglaublich also unglaublich irgendwie
eher so ein Löwe draußen auf der Straße
oder hier im Wald die Suche läuft
überwiegend aus der Luft mit
Wärmebildkameras bisher ohne Erfolg das
ist ja die Suche nach der Nadel im Heu
von daher hoffen wir darauf dass wir
Hinweise aus der Bevölkerung bekommen
was sozusagen Löwen Sichtungen angeht es
ist nicht ausgeschlossen dass die Löwen
aus Privatbesitz entflohen ist die
Gesetzgebung zur Wildtierhaltung ist in
den Bundesländern unterschiedlich
Brandenburg beispielsweise wo der wo die
Löwin ja gesichtet worden ist
anscheinend da darf man tatsächlich
jegliches Tier halten privat auch eine
ein Löwen eine Löwin und das kritisieren
wir natürlich schon seit vielen Jahren
am Nachmittag wurde die Löwin von den
Einsatzkräften erneut gesichtet
aber jetzt Fußball-WM Norbert das war
ein fulminanter Turnierauftakt für die
Gastgeber aus Neuseeland und Australien
wie aus dem Bilderbuch beide gewinnen
ihre eröffnungsspiele beide mit 1:0 der
Sieg soll Neuseelands gegen
Ex-Weltmeister Norwegen schon eine
Sensation denn der klare Außenseiter
hatte bislang bei sechs WM-Turnieren
nicht ein einziges Spiel gewonnen
schon das erste Gruppenspiel wirkte wie
ein Finale die Neuseeländerinnen feiern
ihren historischen Erfolg in der 48
Minute ist es Hannah Wilkinson das eins
zu null durch die Ex Duisburgerin das
erste Tor des Turniers in der 89 Minute
verursacht die norwegeren TÜVer Hansen
einen Handelfmeter Premiere bei dieser
WM Schiedsrichterin jammerita erklärt
ihre Entscheidung über die
Stadionlautsprecher
Rekordnationalspielerin Rea Personal
vergibt und trotzdem Neuseeland jubelt
verdient
ja 40.000 begeisterte Zuschauer in
Auckland in Sydney drei Stunden später
waren es fast doppelt so viele
76.000 feierten dort in mühevollen 1:07
des kogasgebers gegen Irland die Frauen
aus Down Under sind trotzdem eine der
Turnierfavoriten
[Applaus]
gegen die WM debutantinnen aus Irland
war es für die Mathildas jedoch ein
hartes Stück Arbeit Australien
dominierte zwar blieb aber ungefährlich
der Siegtreffer gelang danach diesem
Schauspiel per Elfmeter in der 52 Minute
Stefanie kettley mit dem 1:0 sie Treffer
am Ende haben wir das Ergebnis wir taten
was wir mussten ich bin stolz auf die
Mädels
in der zweiten Hälfte und vor allem in
der starken Schlussphase hatten die
ihren gute Chancen doch ein Tor blieb
den Feiernden Australierinnen
vorbehalten nächstes Spiel Nigeria
die Deutschen freiwasserschwimmer haben
ihr fünftes Gold bei der WM in Japan
verpasst die mix-staffel aus Lea Boy
Leonie Beck muffels und schlussschwimmer
Oliver Klee mit wurde
Freiwasser Doppelweltmeister Florian
Weilburg war nicht dabei erschonte sich
für die anstehenden WM Wettkämpfe im
Becken
alle Freiwasser Goldmedaillen für
Deutschland das wäre auch der Sensation
gewesen
wechselhafte Aussichten gleich von Katja
horneffer schon heute Nacht regnet es im
Westen morgen fast überall das heute
journal um Viertel mit Dunja Hayali wir
wünschen Ihnen noch einen schönen Abend
und bis morgen wenn Sie mögen tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend in den vergangenen 24
Stunden sind kräftige Unwetter über die
Alpen über Oberitalien Slowenien und
Kroatien gezogen dann sind die Gewitter
in sich zusammengefallen und weiter nach
Osten gezogen bei uns gab es doch im
Wesentlichen nur Regenschauer die
Unwetter entwickelten sich an der Grenze
zur großen Hitze und auch heute wurde es
wieder sehr heiß rund um das Mittelmeer
mit Höchstwerten zwischen 33 und 48 Grad
deutlich angenehmer ist das Wetter bei
uns heute Nacht gibt es viele Wolken und
an den Küsten noch einige Gewitter
spätestens in der zweiten Nachthälfte
setzt dann von Westen Regen ein die
Temperaturen sinken auf 16 Grad im
Rhein-Main-Gebiet und bis 9 Grad an der
Trave oder auch in der Uckermark und
morgen liegen die Höchsttemperaturen
entlang der Küsten von Norden Ostsee bei
18 19 Grad sonst werden 20 bis 26 Grad
erreicht und das wird ein sehr
wechselhafter Freitag es gibt immer
wieder Regenschauer und Gewitter die
müssen nicht jeden treffen könnten aber
prinzipiell jeden treffen zwischendurch
werden sie die Sonne zu Gesicht bekommen
bei Westend am Samstag gibt's hier einen
Streifen von der Ostseeküste bis zum
Oberrhein wo sie häufiger die Sonne
sehen können von Nordwesten wenn die
Wolken schon wieder dichter und bringen
Regenschauer und Gewitter mit und auch
am Alpenrand drohen dann zum Nachmittag
Gewitter guten Abend